i want to be able to build
a bridge for marginalized people because
at some point in history
if someone that looked like me was on tv
we were made
or a slave that has evolved and because
i have evolved it is my duty to make
sure that
other marginalized people get to evolve
as well now that i understand that and
now that i'm
in my agency i don't see any reason to
turn back and i don't
[ __ ] have to
it's a weird story actually how i got
the role
first five years before i auditioned
my mother was given the book push
and she was asked to audition for the
role of the mother
which went on to be played by monique
cut to five years later
i had done a bunch of plays
at lehman college and the film was
going there to audition and so a friend
of mine called me and said they're
looking for someone that looks like you
i ended up going to the audition got the
call back for the next day which was
tuesday
i did that and then on wednesday i got
hired
and then we shot like three weeks later
and then
in a year and a half i was nominated for
an oscar
so that's a weird way of becoming an
actor i think
is kind of strange and i didn't really
do it on purpose
but it's probably a good thing it was
good for me that my mom said no
to doing it that would have led to some
very awkward
thanksgiving dinner moment for us i
believe but getting into the character
uh was you know this girl precious she
couldn't read she was way behind other
students
and she didn't necessarily fit in and
she's being
abused at home she's made fun of
away from home there was no rest and no
safety
for her and i think that i was
able to connect to that not that i was
being abused
or living anywhere near a life that
precious was but i understood
hurt on a very human level um
that i think we all can we can all
empathize with pain
in a way and so all i had to do was sort
of center in on that pain
and remember the things that were
painful for me and just
give it to this character and you have
that smirk on your face [ __ ]
now smile about that smile about that
you fat [ __ ]
i had a best friend growing up who her
mother was schizophrenic
and she had been through a quite a bit
of abuse
and she was in therapy at six years old
i
kind of performed as precious for
my friend i thought this is the
character she needs she needs to be able
to see herself
on screen somewhere and so that's what i
was trying to do most
the good thing about it being my first
role is that i didn't really have
time or wherewithal to really think
about the impact of the character
i knew that someone would relate to this
film i don't think i realized
the actual impact people would see me in
the street and they would come up to me
and tell me about how the movie helped
them go through and heal
from their abuse they would tell me
their stories about how
they were victims of incest and now
after seeing the film
they decided to become survivors and
that's not something
i thought was going to be possible with
this character but
i think at this point it's pretty clear
that what i think doesn't matter
to the universe and so thankfully a lot
of people did find
healing and precious any bit of sort of
hardship that i felt either playing the
role or before the role
feels like it was worth it if someone
can watch the performance and watch the
film
and figure out a way to heal themselves
that's the dream i think
i loved american horror story i thought
the first season was the best thing i'd
ever seen on tv
and so when i got the call from ryan to
ryan murphy to take the role of queenie
i was overjoyed i was over the moon i
really really loved it and it was like
witches and i love witches like i really
love spookier things the thing about
like spooky things
is um like a vampire or werewolves or
witches
the only thing you can actually really
become is a witch
you know like it's not as easy to become
a vampire or a werewolf ryan's on the
phone with me and he tells me so you're
a human voodoo doll
so anything you do to yourself another
person can feel and i was
like sold stop selling i got it i'm
there
buy my ticket i think one of the first
tricks i did
was i stabbed myself in the back of the
hand with a fork
it might have been a knife whatever it
was but they built a hand they took my
hand they took pictures
of my skin color and everything and they
built a hand on top of my hand
but in between the hand that they built
and my own hand they put like a steel
plate
with holes in it and the fork that they
gave me was magnetized
so all i had to do was this and then the
fork would find the holes
don't think you [ __ ] stop what i don't
feel nothing i'm a human voodoo doll
and it looked like i stabbed myself and
it was incredible and i was like this is
gonna be so
fun and it was it was really really a
lot of fun to be a witch especially in
new orleans and to get to learn how to
do magic
in that movie magic i guess
lee daniels who directed precious my
first film
he was like i just wrote a script for a
tv show and i want you to read it and i
want you to tell me what you think of it
he had me read the script and i was like
yeah this is cute
like this is good congratulations lily
which is what i call him
and then he said well girl if you want
you can have that role of becky
becky originally was a a small
petite and frail white woman i love
taking white people's jobs
and so he was like if you want becky
which was
more or less kind of like i think she's
just like a throwaway kind of character
i don't i don't know how much thought
was actually put into becky before i
became becky
it just seemed like a fun little project
to do i never shot in chicago and that's
where we shot the pilot and i was like
cool
i usually sign up to things that i think
will be fun i think becky got sort of
bigger as
the seasons went on there were six
seasons
and like fun fact i've never had a job
for that long even before i was an
actress i worked in an
office for three years and that's the
longest job i've ever had and so
empire was like double that what's great
is i could see my character evolve
and i see her grow and i see her style
sort of changes and that was really
really really really fun
where becky began there are definitely
episodes where i didn't even talk i was
just like a very overpaid extra
to then at the very end of the series
opening my own record label with gisele
played by nicole larry parker
your assistant tells me that you're
setting up yana stage concept for the
music weekly show
i completely disagree becky oh you don't
have to agree you know jana's contract
is with bossy and that's me
it was really interesting to see this
character evolve
and grow and i grew and evolved
right with her because as i'm playing
this character as i'm working at this
place
and not just like this place is an
empire like working at fox and like
working at the studio and working with
these people for six years
i grew as a person and i stepped more
and more
into my own agency by the end of the
series i directed
two [ __ ] episodes because i'm dope so
i'm not just an
actor i was also directed two hours of
that show which is incredible i had no
idea that that's
at all what i was going to do with my
life and my career
[Music]
antebellum was a a thrill ride
i loved the script i really loved it one
it's written beautifully
gerard bush and christopher wrens who
are the
co-directors and co-writers they're
extremely talented
and the way that they were so careful
with what we would see i knew that it
was going to
visually be spectacular so the lead
character
is dealing with a lot of slavery
honestly being a slave
is terrible i don't need to list all the
ways in which being a slave is terrible
for you i feel like you know and if you
don't know you're probably a trump
supporter
however she's going through quite a bit
and my portion of the film
i play dawn we're just at dinner and
we're like walking through hotels and
we're doing speeches we're very cute
girls out on the town
here's how that makes sense i had gone
to ghana
we had a lot of fun in ghana but the one
very serious thing we did is we went to
a slave castle
there are four major slave ports in
africa
senegal nigeria ghana and ivory coast
i'm actually senegalese
in ghana at their slave castle literally
on the bottom it's
jails and dungeons and
darkness and anger and hate
and up top there's a beautiful castle
that's where the enslavers lived
slaves were kept there for three months
before walking through the door of no
return
before they were slaves they were
african they were just african people
they were in african society
and the door of no return is what turned
them into a slave
they walk through that door they get on
the boat they come to america
and then that's that and what's
unfortunate
is we think that the beginning of
blackness especially here in america
is slavery and it's not the beginning of
blackness
is way way way way way before slavery
before we were slaves we were africans
and we were mothers and we were fathers
and we were teachers we were doctors we
were an entire society
now i say all that to say the part that
i play
as dawn is i am the society
i'm the society that is going to miss
the slaves i'm the part that is left
behind
i'm the hole and the hole that's missing
and
wants back and also i'm the piece
that the slave needs to find their way
back to i know it's a lot to think of
it might be very far away of a concept
if you're not black and truly understand
really the degradation
of slavery and not just that but the
imprint
of it like i was born in 1983 brooklyn
i've never been a slave
however my dad is senegalese and my
mother is from the south
my mother's people who she was born from
were actually taken
from my father's people after my
parents got married they did a blood
test and realized that they were
actually
of the same family and that's what
slavery does
slavery takes away it takes you from
your society
and it steals you and it steals every
bit of joy and every bit of hope
and mixes you up and you don't know
where you belong
my mother who was born in 1952 georgia
had no idea that she belonged to senegal
her destiny was interrupted
slavery is an interruption that's what
it was it's among other things it's an
interruption
and so antebellum is really about
the interruption of slavery and the
imprint of it and how we still deal with
it today
and you know what's up to this day
they're like civil war reenactments
what are you reenacting you lost it's so
stupid why are we wistful for this
moment
where black people for 400 years were
under your thumb it's bananas
now i don't know if i'll ever play a
slave
and it's certainly not the dream of most
black actors
to play slaves but we get those rules
quite a bit and this is the one time
i didn't have to be a slave but i
absolutely am involved with a film that
is about slavery
[Music]
tara heights was gigantic for me
honestly it was my third audition ever
brett ratner who directed the film he
had me read and i did it
and then he said do you think you can do
an accent
i had done an episode of snl in
one sketch i had a jamaican accent
and so i said to him no can i do
jamaican accent
no go watch snl and see that i can't do
it and he was like let's just try it
let's just try it
and so i did and he liked it and they
got me a dialect coach the thing is
my best friend growing up was jamaican
and her mom had a very thick jamaican
accent
the accent wasn't actually really hard
for me to get what i did run into
trouble
with though on set my accent
was too jamaican and so brett
couldn't understand me and he made me
dial it back
and i've never been more pissed about
anything
i had to do less of a jamaican accent so
that he can understand me
and it's like why can't you just figure
out how to understand me i'm doing this
correctly
but now i have to because like what was
pissing me off was that i knew the
jamaicans that i know
that know i can do the jamaican accent
would be disappointed
i knew that people that didn't know that
i could do the jamaican accent but no
jamaican accent would be disappointed
and transferred to like shaggy one day
was doing some interview about americans
doing jamaican accents and they rated my
accent and he was like and there was one
thing so like
okay i'm very upset so
the line was something about like i have
to go to the store or something i go
meow go to the store
and he didn't understand that he was
like change it to i and i was like no
but it's me
and he's like yeah but just change it to
i and that's the thing that shaggy
pointed out
i know you're a good man mr k even
though you're ruined my life
that goddamn sentence and i was like i
tried i was fighting for it
but they didn't understand me and it's
like it's like get
cultured brett i really tried to argue
like listen you're gonna [ __ ] me up in
the jamaican community okay
i can't go into golden crust having
given
this watered-down jamaican accent
how am i ever going to go get curry goat
again one day i'll let it go
my therapist says i need to let it go
and she's right
that sounds really shady i actually did
have a lot of fun i love
i had a lot a lot of fun actually i had
a i had a really good time on that set
the big c was actually my second
audition my first one was precious the
second one was
big c and the third one was tower heist
so for a bit
i was like pulling off the hat trick i'm
told that that's a sports term
i don't know but the big c was the first
time that i was
actually growing as a character becoming
something different
and changing and i didn't have the whole
story you know like when you're doing tv
you don't actually have the whole story
you don't know it because it's not ended
yet
and it starred laura linney and oliver
platt
and john benjamin hickey and it was such
an incredible
ride i respected laura linney so much
you know she was the helm
she was the leader of the show everyone
that came in she would greet them
if we were with a bunch of extras she
would shake their hands and look them in
the eye
and it's not that i didn't do that
because i think i'm better than other
people
i actually am really really shy having
once been a child
i think that everyone hates me and i
think that most people
don't want to interact with me and so
i just assume that watching laura
interact with people
sort of made me feel like i needed to do
that too that i needed to put away
all the things that you learned about
yourself in junior high i was still
holding on to that and i knew that i had
to be
more like laura because that junior high
gabby didn't exist anymore
it really was school because you have to
remember like it was my third audition
i've never been to acting class i don't
technically
know what i'm doing i'm just sort of
moving
off instinct and my own understanding of
things but i don't have like a technique
in place and like if you need to
cry you do this and if you're a villain
then these are the things that you do
and if you're a good person
and these are like i don't have any of
that and so my school
my teaching came from big c more than
anything
i had to go through that sort of growing
process
while on set which isn't always great i
feel like it's not always great
but i feel like i survived that show and
i feel like i learned a lot from that
show
it helped me to understand what tv is
and how to do tv because tv is different
than film
and also like i was learning about the
kind of comedy i want to do
and the kind of comedic actress i want
to be
i really feel like the big c helped me
shape that